hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine leckere tat und zwar
habe ich eine grapefruit tat gemacht
ursprünglich wollte ich eigentlich nach
orangen tat machen aber ich habe mich
beim einkaufen ehrlich gesagt vergriff
und abfluss mitgenommen und habe dann
gesagt okay jetzt machen sich lothar und
ich bin auch alles richtig froh dass es
jetzt so gemacht habe denn die create
schmeckt richtig lecker ich habe außen
herum einen sehr großen und mögen
möglich dann kommt da eine grapefruit
creme rhein wird zusammen gebacken und
oben habe ich noch karamellisierte krieg
grapefruit scheiben darauf mein gott es
ein schwieriges wort grapefruit und ich
zeige euch jetzt wie man diese leckere
tat backt und werd jetzt zuerst einmal
den map pack vorbereiten
für den mürbeteig brauchen wir 80 gramm
zucker 160 gramm kalte butter 240 gramm
mehl 1 eigelb etwas salz etwas reli
extrakt und eventuell kalte milch der
möglich ist in der herstellung sehr
einfach und sehr schnell
ich nehme es dafür eine küchenmaschine
ihr könnt aber zum beispiel auch einen
multi zerkleinerer nehmen also so ein
mix aufsatz und es darin machen oder das
rasch mit den händen verkneten ich mache
es jetzt hier kurz mit so einem flach
höfer gibt woche die kalte butter in die
schüssel
da kommt zucker mit rein politisch das
alles gibt's auch direkt mitteilen
und lass es ganz kurz verrühren dann
kann sich nämlich die gute später besser
in den teig einführen
aber wie gesagt nichts mehr angeht das
auto ganz schnell gebe ich auch direkt
ob vanille extrakt und das eigelb mit
hut
und zum schluss kommt es noch das mehl
betreiben
und sobald sich alles verbunden hat mich
einfach mal mit den händen den teig
kneten und schauen ob wir jetzt zu
trocken ist wenn ja gibt dir noch ein
mini schluck milch mit rein also gerade
so 1 esslöffel und wenn er gut ist also
bei mir seit gut wenn ich ihn zusammen
drücke bleibt schön zusammen
dann braucht ihr keine milch muss ich
den tag einfach nur noch kurz den händen
zusammen kneten
dafür gebe ich ihnen jetzt hier auf die
arbeitsfläche jetzt kurz und ganz
schnell arbeiten damit datei gibt nicht
warm wird
ich hab zwar kalte butter benutzt aber
ich muss den teig jetzt trotzdem für
eine halbe stunde in den kühlschrank
stellen damit er noch mal richtig schön
kalt wird und lass ihn da etwas vor
der teig besitzt abgekühlt und jetzt
kann ich ihn ausrollen und habe ziel
bereits eine tat form gerichtet und zwar
hat die 25 zentimeter im durchmesser und
hat diesen hebel boden damit ich später
die tat gut rausgekommen und durch diese
perforierung wird der teig später eben
richtig schön kross und knusprig den tag
habe ich einmal kurz durch geknetet und
rollen jetzt auf etwa 29 cm aus also 4
cm mehr sitzt der durchmesser der form
damit ich gleich auch einen hand hat
den teig rolle ich jetzt auf das
nudelholz warmes clowns eigentlich sagt
man es gar nicht mehr aus dem staub so
wie ich da die form es drunter und kann
das jetzt hier drüber wieder ausrollen
es müsste gucken wenn sie das ist nicht
schlimm kann man wieder dran kleben und
dann einfach schön in die form reinlegen
den überschuss nehme ich jetzt einfach
mit seiner palette weg aber nach außen
hinweg streichen und damit der teig
erstmal vorgebacken und zwar im ofen bei
180 grad ober unterhitze für 15 minuten
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich dann
schon mal die füllung vorbereiten aber
feuchten und tag hinein gebe stehe ich
ihnen mehrmals mit einer gabel ein und
zwar bleibt er dann beim backen flach
und ich spare mir einfach den aufwand
jetzt mit dem blitz packen also mit dem
backpapier und diesen bug bohnen die es
gibt
ich habe die zutaten für die füllung
gerichtet in der zwischenzeit habe ich
aber auch schon mal die teig reste noch
als kekse ausgestochen die könnte
einfach immer so mit verwerten
aber wenn samira da ist danach stehen
meistens aber einfach den rohen teig
verbilligtes früher gemacht habt oder
auch heute in natura da vorne stehen die
zutaten
ich habe für die füllung 40 gramm zucker
3 gelbe 40 km speisestärke 400 gramm
schmand und eine bio grapefruit ich
wollte ursprünglich eigentlich eine
orangen tat machen
aber irgendwie habe ich auch so seine
bio grapefruit gekauft und sind eine
grapefruit tat ist genauso gut deswegen
jetzt die genommen zuerst muss ich jetzt
die schale reiben abreiben und zwar habe
ich die grapefruit bereits heiß
abgewaschen
aber ihr solltet definitiv eine
biografie oder bio orange nehmen
valletta einfach weil die einfach
unbehandelt sind
dann muss ich noch den saft auspressen
ich finde grapefruit halt immer eine
richtig tolle farbe also irgendwelches
kein orange aber auch kein pink gegen
eine mischung
den saft fülle ich jetzt in einen
kleinen topf und gibt er den zucker mit
rein und lass es einmal ganz kurz
erhitzen damit sicher weiter zucker
auflösen kann
das muss nicht auf kochen sondern nur
warm werden und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich schon mal hier
die eigelbe reingeben und die
speisestärke und die zwei zutaten mit
der grapefruit schale verrühren
jetzt gebe ich ein bisschen saft mit zur
der eigelb mischung und verrührt es
miteinander einfach damit gleich
leichter weiter rühren kann
jetzt gebe ich noch den rest mit rein
jetzt kommt hier noch der schwanz mit
rein und vielen dank für den tipp mit
dem lock und zwar hat mir eine
zuschauerin geschrieben
ich habe bei dem stand neulich aus dem
becher bekommen immer dann noch rein
macht dann löst sich einfach also dann
geht halt das vakuum weg und da kommt
luft rein und dann kommt er schon drei
gleich groß
und jetzt beim tag der rand manchmal so
ein bisschen hochgeht nämlich einfach so
ein kleines ghs oder was anderes
streiche entlang und dann haben wir den
auch wieder schön flach und jetzt fühle
ich hier diese masse ein
und dann muss der kuchen noch mal fertig
gebacken werden und zwar nochmal bei der
gleichen temperatur für 25 minuten
die tat ist gebacken und ich habe es ja
auch abkühlen lassen
nach dem backen ist immer noch so ein
bisschen flüssig wird aber dann mit dem
abkühlen fest und jetzt möchte ich da
noch karamellisierte grapefruit
schreiben obendrauf legen ich meine die
tat so schon gut aus schmeckt sicherlich
auch so schon hervorragend aber ich
finde es macht dann nochmal so das
gewisse etwas aus und die tag dann auch
noch mal richtig schön
deswegen brauche ich auch hier nochmal
eine bio great food sprach 100
milliliter wasser und 100 gramm braunen
zucker
jetzt könnt ihr statt dem wasser zum
beispiel auch also statt 100 gramm
wasser könnte die hälfte also 50 gramm
beispielsweise auch durch rum ersetzen
und hab da einfach nur mal so einen
intensiveren aromatischen geschmack
jetzt nehme ich aber erstmal die
grapefruit und nehme jetzt die
grapefruit so dass sich schöne scheiben
schneiden kann das heißt ich muss sie
jetzt muss jetzt oben den deckel
wegschneiden sodann hat man nämlich hier
diese schöne optik wenn ihr nämlich
andersrum schneidet die nicht so schön
aus jetzt schneide ich hier so dünne
scheiben mit etwa 13 4 millimeter runter
ihr könnt natürlich auch vorher die
schale entfernen bzw
müsste dann also komplett mit dem weiß
wegnehmen dann habt ihr auch diese
bitterstoffe nicht mit drin aber ich
finde so siehts hübscher aus also müsst
ihr einfach selber entscheiden wird es
machen möchte
ich bin das karamell einfach diese
bitterstoffe so ein bisschen ausgleicht
jetzt gebe ich den zucker in einem topf
oder bzw in der pfanne und gibt ihn
zukommt
das wasser mit rein dann lasse ich diese
zuckerwasser mischung aufkochen
und jetzt sobald es kopf lege ich die
scheiben mit rein und es liegt jetzt
echt schon richtig gut
und jetzt lasse ich das so lange auf dem
herd bis die feuchtigkeit weg ist also
die flüssigkeit verdampft ist und es
anfing zu karamellisieren müsste eben
dabei stehen bleiben damit sie euch
nicht verbrennen
beim karamellisieren habe ich jetzt
immer darauf geachtet dass ich immer
wieder von den sirup etwas über die
grapefruit scheiben gießen
jetzt habe ich sie ganz gut stehen
lassen damit ich mir die finger nicht
verbrennen
jetzt muss für die scheiben ganz
vorsichtig rausnehmen und da drauf sitzt
und jetzt müsst ihr das karamell noch
ganz heiß nehmen und könnt da zum
beispiel noch ein bisschen drüber
pinseln gerne auch hier drüber
wenn es karamell zwischendurch fest wird
muss es einfach nur mal ganz kurz
aufkochen und dann schnell wieder den
herd aus sondern könnt ihr wieder weiter
pinsel jetzt wieder schön flüssig
wenn er töpfe und pfannen übrigens
wieder von karamell befreien wollte dir
einfach ein bisschen wasser mit ein
ich hab ja zum beispiel auch das besteck
mit rein weil da ganz viel karamell dran
war und man im spülbecken schlecht
sauber bekommt ja da kommt wasser rein
lässt aufkochen das karamell schmilzt ja
dann in dem wasser und löst sich auf und
dann bekommt ihr das eben ganz rasch
wieder sauber
die tat ist fertig abgekühlt und jetzt
kann ich es herausnehmen und es geht
jetzt ganz einfach da ja die tat vom mit
dem hebel boten
jetzt kann die tat probieren wir sind
echt aus wie gemalt
finde ich auch ich finde dass man
wirklich die schale an den great
brotscheiben dran lassen muss auf jeden
fall weil das bittere gibt auf jeden
fall verloren und es hat einen richtig
tollen geschmack
vielleicht könntest du mir mal wieder
meine messer schärfen dieser ignorierte
ich habe so viel zeit also ich hier
unten
der leckere feine mittag dann die diese
cremige konsistenz von der füllung und
oben die karamellisiertem grapefruit
scheiben ich muss einmal erzählt problem
und ich mache das ganz einfach ich es so
gut halten ist ja das schöne an der tat
wenn die tat richtig gut ist dann kannst
du am boden bist zu halten oder so um
zusammen denn du bist der tat experte
oder wie ich muss sagen der morath mag
eigentlich nicht habt immer wenn ich
zeit habe ich meine tat hieß es immer
aber bitte noch keine partei ich mag
keine maschine herzhaft keine herzhaften
herzhaft mit zurück aber die schmeckt
richtig gut und ich finde dieses also so
ein bisschen kommt das bittere noch
durch von der great aber ich finde es
richtig gut also ich finde es hat
wirklich sehr sehr lecker
das könnte man machen immer sonntags den
tatort anschauen wenn euch diese stadt
investiert und jedes gerne nachmachen
wollte angeht auf meinem blog auf sally
blog.de doch stets noch mal ich würde
mich freuen wenn jetzt nach macht es
wirklich ein sehr leckeres rezept auch
ein sehr einfaches rezept also man muss
jetzt nicht so mega viel beachten
und es sind auch nicht ja keine zu
ausgefallenen zutaten
gerne können jetzt auch mit orangen
machen oder gerne auch mit gewürzen
verfeinert
wenn ihr das möchte und ich freue mich
auf jeden fall über mit foto und wünsche
ich ganz viel spaß beim nachbacken und
wir sehen uns dann das nächste mal
wieder biss dann tschüss